ilo35 so we've played e4 but let's
actually play d
okay let's not play d4 um
that was such a powerful move that the
game was supported um
[Music]
you know somebody in youtube asked me to
play d4
and talk a little bit about how to play
d4 system so we might try something like
the london system
uh which i know is not everybody's cup
of tea uh
but i i'm sensitive to the fact that
people play different openings okay
let's hope that this is a little bit
better
i'm going to play the london system here
and i'm going to try to okay i guess i'm
not gonna play the london he plays c5
so that's the bononi and after the game
i'll explain what happens if you take
the pawn but normally in the banoni you
want to advance the pawn to d5 thank you
reinhardt for the prime
and he plays the move b5 that's a weird
system and when you play
d4 openings the basic opening principles
remain
exactly the same as when you play e4
openings so when our opponent plays on
the flank like this what should we do
how should we respond should we imitate
him and play on the flank as well or
should we play in the center
uh we should play in of course the
center and what should we do we should
play e4
and immediately we pose a threat to the
pawn which he defends now
one of the key concepts in d4 openings
is
the positional elements of the game
usually come out a little bit
a little bit uh sooner and one of the
things that i want to do is i want this
c4 square
for either my bishop or my knight you
guys can see that this bishop is a
little bit cramped i can't really
develop it so how can we go about and i
call this concept carving out
we can play the move a4 you'll see this
move very often in these types of
openings and the idea is
not mysterious we are carving out the c4
square
so that our bishop can get up get more
active potentially this knight can also
maneuver itself to c4 very typical idea
in the minoni for now let's just keep
developing our pieces
uh so and no joke thank you for the sub
okay so now we're just developing our
pieces
and uh one good idea in in such
positions
is also to prevent him from going a5 and
buttressing this pawn on b4 how can we
go about doing that
thank you reinhardt 13 to the 5 gifted
appreciate it
how can we stop him from going a well
obviously we can play a5 ourselves so
isn't this pawn going to be weak you may
ask
no it's not because the rook defends it
and if you think about it he has no way
to increase the pressure on this pawn
now we can't get our bishop out right
hope that makes sense to everybody
because he takes on b2 we don't want to
give away a pawn for free
so how can we blunt his bishop so that
our bishop
may have a path toward development thank
you while
snipers yeah we can just play c3 so that
now we can develop our bishop
and as a bonus if he takes on c3 well
guess what
our knight is going to have a nice
development square on c3
100 bits thank you so he's probably
going to go nice sorry he's probably
going to go
knight f6 and attack the pawn on e4 he's
having some internet problems man my
moves are so
strong that they're literally causing my
opponent's internet to just
disconnect so let's defend this pawn now
there's a couple of ways to do that
thank you guys for the sub
we can go knight bd2 right but the
drawback of that would be
that our bishop would then not be able
to develop itself so let's defend the
pawn of the rook
so that our bishop can then move out and
then we'll be able to develop our knight
to d2
and everything will be nicely developed
yeah this looks like some internet
issues okay obviously we're gonna go
bishop g5 we're gonna go go to the most
active square
four would also have been possible uh
again i i emphasize this point a lot
uh sometimes there's more than one good
square for a piece you shouldn't think
of it like oh
every one of my pieces needs to be you
know figuring out a way to distribute
the covet vaccine like no
you know sometimes pieces can be in a
mediocre spot and that's okay
as long as there's other pieces that are
doing the heavy lifting okay
so 98 now what strikes me about this
move
what is what does he want what he wants
is is to prevent my knight from coming
out to d2
why does he prevent my knife from coming
to d2 because if you notice he's got two
attackers on the c3 pawn he's going to
win that pawn so so let's preemptively
defend the c3 pawn so that we can uh
we can get our knight out how can we can
do that in several different ways
one good way of doing that is to bring
our queen out to c2
which also has the positive effect of
reinforcing
the pawn on e4 he goes f6 very strange
play
very passive but uh that's not going to
stop us from adhering to our main
strategy we're going to go he's probably
going to go h5 i think that's what he
wants if i'm
getting the right read no knight c7 okay
so
how do we respond when our opponent
plays this passively and i've mentioned
this many times before
when our opponent plays passively what
is the main thing that we have to do
in order to expose or better expose
uh the i would say the poverty of his
device should open the center as much as
we can
now we can't go e5 because that pawn is
that square is perfectly protected
but we can take on b4 now you guys might
look at this and we'll wait a second
you're not really opening the center but
i'm opening something i'm opening the c
file and by trading pawns whenever
pawns are traded even on the side of the
board what you need to do is look at
which squares
are now made available to your pieces
which previously previously defended
squares
can we now take up with our pieces and
as you guys are pointing out
we can put our knight in the center
where is this night going several
possibilities
look at this beautiful outpost look at
this beautiful outpost thank you the
real black stallion
beautiful squares that the knight can
access all of our pieces are nicely
developed we can also bring the rook
into the game with rook c1 remember that
the c
file has been opened uh either square is
good it depends on what he does if he
goes bishop b7
well then we can still put our knight on
c6 yeah i think you guys are
are taking a fancy tonight now i don't
like the fact that this knight is on c5
can we get this knight out of here can
we trade it that night is his only
active piece
and oftentimes you want to search for
your opponent's only active piece
i know that some of you guys are
wondering why i didn't take the pawn
i'll explain that after the game thank
you
zlorian for the prime um
one sec and i'm noting stuff down to not
forget
why not knight takes b4 so we're trying
to trade his only active piece
our knight remains on a beautiful
outpost if he takes
what are we going to take back with uh
i mean and both pieces are fine but
remember that the c file
has been opened so our queen is actually
very nicely positioned
uh which means that we can take with our
bishop and we can open up that c file
for our queen this creates potential for
discovered attacks
against this knight on c7 remember that
this knight on c7 is unprotected
so we should be watching watch okay so
he wants to trap our bishop let's
prevent him from doing that before we do
anything else thank you macko with a
tier 2
oh look that's what we're talking about
thank you appreciate it yeah okay great
i don't care uh and and the reason i'm
so dismissive about this
which you shouldn't be about your
opponent's ideas is because he has no
pieces in the attack so there's no way
this is going to work
okay so let's continue bringing our
pieces
into the game uh let's bring a rook well
we can bring it out well let's get it on
c1
let's bring our rook into the game exit
thank you scrammy dangles thank you guys
for all this incredible support
and i'll thank people properly after the
game as you can see
my time is running a little bit short so
at some point i might have to accelerate
the pace of my play
so right now we're bringing all of our
pieces into the game and
uh let's get our queen to a more central
location so that if he plays rook ca
uh we don't have to worry about the fact
that he pins our queen and we can
finally then come around and take this
pawn on b4
uh why are we not afraid of him taking
the knight i will explain that well
i'll explain that in the game what
should we take back with
what should we take back this is a
pretty instructive moment a case could
be made for both pieces
but we're going to take with a pawn
because look at this pawn it's very far
advanced
we also open up the bishop's diagonal
toward his king
and where can we plant this bishop we
can plant it all the way on e6 what does
this move accomplish
well for for one thing it just freezes
his pieces and for another thing it
covers the c8 square
why is this square important because
that's the square from which you can
stop the progress of our pawn so we're
literally threatening to promote this
pawn
which is quite rare for a middle game
but now we're going to slam this bishop
onto d7
he's done a good job of blockading the
pawn but now his knight is super passive
so uh but so what should we do in a
scenario like this when his pieces are
incredibly passive
but we can't quite find the crushing
blow
well what's the sort of typical
prescription that i always offer in
these situations we should open up the
position a little bit more
can we open up the position a little bit
more we shouldn't sack on d6 that would
be a little bit overzealous
but we can play the move f4 now i know
you guys are looking at this move and
saying but wait a minute
aren't you opening up a direct line of
fire toward my king
and the answer to that is yes i am but
on the other hand i'm also
you know everything here is reciprocal
because his king is also on this side of
the board so what my judgment tells me
is that because my pieces are so much
better placed
i'm going to be better equipped to
handle the opening of the position than
he is
if he puts a rook on g8 okay big deal
i'm just going to defend the pawn on g2
so there's no shenanigans
with a discovered attack but after that
his pawn on h4 becomes weak
he goes bishop h6 so he's not playing
badly
uh now i'm not gonna take on h6 let's
trade on my own terms i'm gonna go rook
f1
so that if he takes my bishop the rook
comes into the game and guess what that
h4 pawn
is going to be in big trouble he keeps
on disconnecting i think that's pretty
much hurting his chances
yeah rook takes g rook takes f4
okay what should we do now we have a
winning sequence can somebody spot the
entire thing
thank you channel for the 500 bed so
first we do what first we collect the
harvest
do not take this one he's trying to
trick us first we take h4
his king has to move and after his king
moves as you guys are
correctly pointing out good job rook g4
pins his queen to his king there we go
you see what happens we open up the
position he's not ready for it he
doesn't have the pieces to defend
against it
and okay he's gonna lose on time but
just to show everybody king g7 rook g4
is a typical pin that rook is defended
and we win as queen
so let's go over the game briefly
although i think everything was
relatively clear there's a couple of
moments to point out
uh the move c5 is the old called the old
benoni defense
and a lot of you may be wondering why i
didn't
why is this not a free pawn well there's
a complicated reason for this
uh black can win it back immediately
with queen a5
but that's not actually what most people
do here because that brings the queen
out early
you don't necessarily want to do that
normally i think the black plays e6 here
and tries to take back the pawn with his
bishop
and if we stubbornly try to defend this
pawn
and i'm just making verifying this yes
so how should black proceed in this
position
we have a pawn chain you guys already
know the principle i've shared it many
times we attack
the base of the pawn chain and when we
have softened up the base of the pawn
chain then we attack the tip
audi attack thank you for the prime
because the base is weak we can take the
base and then we can take the tip
black has a great center black has a
great position
so clinging to the pawn is not a good
prescription for this position that's
why we go d5 and clay more of the center
we also prevent his knight from
developing to its natural square
b5 is i'm sure a move i've not really
seen this before
uh and we responded by occupying more of
the center now we do this carving out
mechanism
uh and let me just pop open chess space
if you guys don't mind for a second
and i want to show a very typical
application of this concept i know it's
a
little bit boring to some of you but i
believe this is very important
this concept of carving out uh where
does it manifest itself in real games
can you
like i get it daniel you're doing it in
this king can you show me a grandmaster
game where this happens
i absolutely can and uh you guys will
just have to give me a second
to find one because i didn't have it
prepared that's part of the fun of the
speedrun i never know which concepts
are going to be you know i'm going to be
able to illustrate but here's a good
example from a game
over 100 years ago which black did not
end up winning but
he did apply the concept so tarus
against
duras so the concept of carving out or
undermining
is a concept where your opponent has a
pawn that pawn is on a particular square
and it's covering a square where you
really want to put one of your pieces
you have a piece you want to put it on a
square your opponent has a pawn that's
covering that square what do you do
well you use one of your pawns to
undermine or
literally take that pawn which is
covering the square you want to get to
channel no 5 thinking for the prime
so this was 1912 two of the leading
players of the day
what did black do in this position which
square do we want to access how do we
carve that square out
b5 is correct so if we think about this
knight on f6 right the knight doesn't
have any good squares
it doesn't have any prospects because
every square that it could potentially
go to is covered by one of white's
pieces
so duras plays b5 carving out the d5
square for his knight tara
advances duress drops his bishop back
and look at how beautiful this outpost
on d5 is unassailable night
uh and the game ended in a draw black
was not able to win but he was better
and tarash did something super clever
here tarash was like whoa whoa whoa not
on my watch
that night on d5 it looks unassailable
but i'm gonna assail it so what do you
think tarash did here
to try to trade this knight on d5 carson
thank you for the front
and i'll explain what happens if white
plays b3
so yeah knight a2 now he doesn't move
the other night because his other knight
is already on an outpost
so and this is actually something that
you want to do right when you're trying
to
accomplish a task on the chessboard and
there are several pieces to do it with
you want to make sure that you're using
the piece that's most passive
so that you don't accidentally dislodge
a piece that's already on a good square
and now we get the night to see through
welcome charlotte chess center
and uh yeah so so now we get the knight
to c3 and he trades the knight
and uh unfortunately duress has to take
it so the game ends in a drop
now if white had gotten b3 in this
position
uh then i think he was afraid of his
king getting opened up so something like
this would have happened
and then he gets his queen to b4 this
just doesn't look doesn't look
particularly appetizing for white
at all so that's in a nutshell the
concept of carving out that's what we
did
in my game okay
so that's what we did in my game
and now we get the bishop to c4 so it's
the same concept it's a different piece
and basically now we continue our
developments
okay now we go e5 to stop him from
coming a5 himself
now we go c3 to be able to develop this
bishop
and now we go bishop g5 x flank 4. thank
you for the prime
and uh basically everything we do here
is in order to be able to develop other
pieces so
here we can't move our knight out
because we're going to blunder the pawn
and uh here that's why we play queen c2
okay so now we take on d
on b4 in order to open up the center i'm
going to skip right to an important
moment why didn't we take on b4
wasn't this just a free bond that we
could have captured with our knife
and the answer really is yes it was but
sometimes
your piece is so well placed that you
don't actually want to move it away from
its outpost even for a
night sorry even for a pawn for a night
you would totally move the knight from
c6
i hope that concept makes sense it's not
all about material sometimes the piece
is so active
that you want to keep it on a square at
all costs and i didn't want to get way
laid by this pond i thought this pawn
isn't going anywhere
so that's why we tried to trade his
strongest piece instead
okay so h5 h3 and the rest was very
straightforward to get our rook to a
good square
um so why not h4 here instead yeah we
could have gone h4 but i was a little
bit worried about weakening my king
uh before i'm ready to do so so i
decided to play h3 which is a more
modest move
trying to get him to be the one to
weaken his king which is exactly what he
did
um emails asks what if he goes e6 at any
point trying to take away the d5 pawn
uh this would be a sensible move right
because he's trying to undermine
my knight from c6 right he's trying to
undermine the base of the knight what
would i have done if he goes e6 can can
somebody tell me
what would white do if he goes e6 bishop
takes d6 is correct
yes exactly bishop takes d6 and
we just win everything and that's
something you have to just learn how to
do
as a matter of habit thank you ghost dlb
for the prime and horror plation
which is that when your opponent moves
upon and his position is already very
fragile to begin with
uh you need to sort of get into the
habit of checking which
pawns and pieces are left unattended as
a consequence of that it's the same
exact thing
that we did here right i'm like okay
well which squares have been made
available
to my pieces ah i can get my knight to
d4 and i can centralize it
and bring it to an outpost innovative
panda asks when black played g5
it's sacrificing the knight to open up
the king work so
we could have considered yeah so i could
have done this
but i didn't see a need to do it right
it's like i'm already better
i've got positional advantages why risk
it with a sacrifice particularly since i
don't have that many pieces in the
attack
he can sorry i didn't mean to play them
if he can bring his own knight in he can
bring his bishop in
so i wasn't just sure that it was worth
doing it in a position like this i'm not
really desperate if that makes sense
and the last thing i wanted to draw your
attention to
is this moment right why did we take
with the pawn and now with the rook
now why would we have taken with a rook
because we here we can get both rooks to
the c
file that would have also been good but
i judged
that the fact that the bishop gets open
you know a
and b how close the pawn is to promotion
and c
the fact that i'm now blocking his rook
from coming to c8
crippling his pieces permanently there's
just too many pros
versus uh to not play this so it's just
a judgment call
you know it's like uh you're it's
there's no rocket science to the
art of making a decision like this i'm
just weighing the pros and cons
right okay here the rook is very good
that's one thing
but here i've got all sorts of things
that that are given to me
um and the last thing i did of course
was open up the position open up the
king side
because his pieces are so passive that's
basically our main principle
all right so let's once again try to get
a london system in
uh and this time he plays d6 so i
suppose we can technically still play
the london
f5 okay so he transposes into a dutch
and uh if you're a london player then
then there's no particular way that you
should respond differently to the dutch
you should play
the typical london system moves and in
the london you develop your bishop to f4
i think most people probably have seen
this opening before
now um there are several things that we
can
do uh in order to respond i think
accurately to the fact that our opponent
is playing the dutch
the move f5 if you think about it from a
general perspective
it weakens this diagonal right it moves
upon out which means he's going to have
a
difficult time castling if and only if
we do what
where should we develop one of our
pieces in order to
in order to delay and and sort of try to
slow down
his development let's go bishop c4 so
not only does this slow down castling
but it also makes it very hard well it
makes it harder for him to go e6 he
manages to do it
but now we have in our pocket the idea
of going knight g5
but let's not do that immediately let's
complete our development let's be
patient
that's what you do in the london system
h3 is also a very typical move
giving the bishop the h2 square and now
we need to start expanding on
the queen side so let's do that by
playing c4
very typical move in d4 openings aren't
we blunting the bishop i see some of you
guys looking at this
aren't we blunting our bishop well we
kind of are but what i'm banking on is
that eventually we're going to be able
to play c5
we're going to reopen the diagonal for
the bishop and we're going to increase
the queenside
pawn pressure we're going to turn the
dial up on the queen side okay so right
now we're just developing or grabbing
space
and of course he can castle we can't
permanently stop him from castling but
we're going to discourage it
because he's always going to have to
deal with this kind of pressure thank
you xemias for the
for the prime and channel for the 100
bits
um okay so
okay um now let's see what what happens
here
all right um
so let's see what happens here he's
deep in thought i mean i think he's yeah
so he decides to castle
now we're going to continue our
development with knight to c3
uh and and slowly but surely we're going
to prepare
either the c5 pawn break or we could
also try to prepare the e4
pawn break in order to make it easier
for us to attack the e6 pawn
he goes a6 that's kind of an empty move
now in in the interest of preparing c5
what kind of move can we consider which
may potentially help us prepare c5 and
this is a very typical move
in such positions again you want to make
sure that
you're playing to take care of your
future self uh it's not all about
immediate threats because somebody might
look at this move and say well wait a
minute you're not preparing c5
because there's the knight on cp i know
that but we're doing it in the long run
and i'm going to share with you guys a
very interesting plan in this position
what would make it easier for us to
prepare c5 right
well wouldn't it be nice ladies and
gentlemen to have a pawn on b4
i mean then c5 would be much easier now
why can't we play b4 well there's a
bishop on b3 and if we move
the bishop to c2 well we would get it
off the main diagonal
and the bishop would miss the party and
we would blunder the c4 knight so how do
we solve this problem
we need to get this bishop to a
different square we can't get it to a2
but we can play a3
get the bishop back and then send the
pawn forward and i'll show you guys
an example from one of my games where i
lost
to a very similar idea and i've learned
this idea from that game
and i haven't forgotten it since so this
is a pretty depositional idea and it's
going to make it very hard for him
to stop c5 even if he goes a5
it's still gonna be hard for him to stop
b4 so let's proceed with our plan
okay and
guess what we are ready to play c5 and
finally to reopen this bishop on a2
so it's a long-term process oh and he
actually kind of helps us do it
he's trying to carve out the d5 score
but the d5 square is very well protected
by our pieces we shouldn't worry about
him getting a knight there
precisely because the bishop and our
knight are guarding that square
okay bishop c6 what should we do now
paying very careful attention to the
drawbacks of this move
and this is exactly why we tried to open
up the bishop that's working like
a knife through butter what can we do
what has he left unattended boom goes
the dynamite we can just take on e6
well who said we can't take two puns who
said we can't take two
free puns okay i'm not sure why this
trade is helpful for him but now we're
attacking the rook
i'm very hungry
okay so how should we go about
managing our massive position here
obviously we're dominating here
but a lot of people struggle with this
moment and and understandably so
so one thing that i want to one one idea
that i have right if you look at this
king very carefully
he doesn't have a light squared bishop
what does that mean
that means that if we build a battery
with our bishop and our queen
he's going to have a very hard time
stopping it because he's not going to be
able to put a light squared bishop in
the face of our bishop
now you guys already know that if you
think about queen bishop batteries
the queen in front of the bishop is a
lot more powerful because the queen
could be the one delivering the maid
so let's bring our bishop back to b1 i'm
not threatening queen e4 i know that
square is defended
but it's the same exact principle as
earlier i'm anticipating that in the
future we might try to get this knight
out of f6
and or what is the other thing we can do
we could just circumvent it we could
just bring the queen to c2
then we could try to get rid of the
knight and then guess what we're gonna
try to end this game by delivering a
checkmate on h7
look at his knight on a7 by the way
fantastic piece
okay so we're why not queen d3 doesn't
matter either move is good queen d3
maybe he'll put a rook on d8
and x-ray the queen so the queen is a
long distance piece
all right let's get the bishop up to e5
we are actually
poised to take the knight on it but we
don't need to do it yet
and this is something i want to
emphasize to people we don't need to
hurry with something that's not going
anywhere
even if we don't get to take this knight
he's permanently weakened at the
diagonal
now we have a really strong move here
which basically ends the game
we have several moves that basically end
the game one
is well if we take on f6 he's going to
take with the bishop and his queen
continues to defend the square on h7 so
what we can do is go 94
and what we're threatening to do is take
twice on f6 eventually his queen is
going to have to recapture
and then the h7 square is free for our
queen
he correctly goes queen to g7 now
how can we add some tabasco sauce to
this knight on f6 can we can we find a
way to pressure that knight in another
way
and there's no more pieces that can do
that immediately so we're going to have
to open up some files
let's add that tabasco sauce f4 we're
trying to open if he goes g4
then we can just take on g4 remember his
queen is tied down
to the h7 square it can't defend it
cannot move anywhere because the moment
it moves uh we are going to take on f6
with a knight and we're going to travel
with our queen to h7
boom and guess which square we're going
to deliver boom
and that's it he doesn't boom boom boom
and we're going to mate him on h7
exactly as we thought initially because
well it's not a surprise when we were
building that battery he already didn't
have anything to stop us with okay
he's gonna give up his rook but that
doesn't matter now he's down a rook
and he can't even take twice on f6 here
either
okay we're gonna bring that final rook
into the game remember the key principle
even when you're up material don't
forget to employ all of your pieces
okay and i hope you guys don't mind if i
munch on some
armenian bread here okay we
he resigns so a nice game rook f8 was
not course mate
guys if you got to be very careful with
the sacrifices because the rook on e7
guards age seven
and so this is not checkmate and this is
something i have shared with people you
might be watching my blitz games and
assume uh you know you want to sacrifice
in every position
but sometimes if you're agonizing over
whether to sacrifice you got to realize
you're up a rook
what's the necessity what's the need in
doing something that might backfire
so sometimes it's worth playing with an
abundance of caution
what happened in this game we you ask
questions now this is the postmortem the
autopsy
we go over the game i explain some of
the decisions and you guys can ask
questions i can't get to every question
but i can do my best
okay uh so the game started with the
london system bishop f4
he transposed from the perk into the
dutch with f5 thank you fire dude for
the prime
i appreciate it and i know a lot of
people are fans of the london system
so i decided to play it i got some
youtube comments requesting that
uh the london system is fine as a
beginner
now bishop c4 so generally in the london
and
i will explain this through the lens of
d4 d5
zaryani thank you for the prime the line
it is an opening where white goes bishop
f4
and then generally establishes a
stronghold on the d4 square he puts
pawns on e3 and d3 creating this pawn
triangle
and then the bishop the dark the light
square bishop generally goes in the
middle of the pawn triangle
but one thing that's very important to
understand when you're playing an
opening
that that's what i call a schematic
opening an opening where you play the
same set of moves
over and over again you want to be very
very careful
because sometimes your opponent does
something which requires you to think
outside the box and play a move which is
normally not part of the opening setup
this is exactly that kind of case right
normally in the london as i just
explained
the bishop goes either to d3 or to e2
but this is an extenuating situation
because he's played f5 he's weakened
this diagonal so now we
we dynamically react by developing the
bishop to c4
and controlling this diagonal i hope
that makes sense
okay um wayne rooney asks a great
question why not d5 well yes
you're exactly right wayne rooney this
creates a massive weakness on e5 which
we can later occupy with an item
this is not the end-all be-all for the
bishop we could go c4
and much like we did in the game we can
try to open that bishop back up
okay so knight b6 e6 and really the
critical moment of the game
and by the way the the reason that h3 is
often played in the london
is because after knight h5 uh he will be
unable to root out the bishop due to
bishop h2 okay
so a wolf in water thank you for the
tier one and again
uh good evening to everybody those are
over 5 000 those of you joining from
chess tv welcome it's and it's an
honor to have so many of you here for
something that i know people enjoy and i
enjoy so much
uh so we're having a great time and i
hope you guys are are
are having a good time as well i just
want to thank everybody for this massive
support
uh that i'm experiencing here it's it's
it's a really amazing so
thank you all hash me appreciate it okay
um so this idea that i came up with of
a3 bishop a2 and b4
and i feel like mr bean explaining
whistler's mother here
what did i learn from this experience in
los angeles so let me show you guys the
stem game where did i learn about this
idea
and hopefully this is going to convince
people of the importance of of learning
from your own losses
no matter how painful they are this is
the position in which i was playing with
the white pieces i was playing a
grandmaster from indy abhijit gupta very
strong player 2600
and in this position he played the move
queen to b6 this is a french
right you guys can understand why he
played queen b6 2 dragon thank you for
the prime he is exerting pressure on the
d4 pawn
he's got now three defenders on the pawn
i've got only sorry three attackers on
the pawn i've got two defenders
so he is threatening to capture this
pawn and with this pawn comes the other
pawn
this is just a very very bad uh very
very bad position so what did i do i
played the move queen a4 and i'm saying
okay
well you have three attackers now i have
another defender
and my opponent did something here which
i never forgot
he came up with a brilliant idea now
what my opponent
asked himself here is which of white's
three defenders
constitutes the weak link if you can
remove one of these three defenders
from the pawn then this pawn will
collapse and when that's when this pawn
collapses my whole
position collapses now generally
speaking paradoxically enough as you
guys know
the weakest link is the strongest piece
because it is the easiest to attack
if you attack the queen the queen
normally has to move uh which means that
he paid attention to the queen
but it's not easy to get rid of this
queen without also
getting well you can drop your queen
back and go knight p6 congratulations
but you've also then removed an attacker
on the d4 pawn
and as some of you guys are already
pointing out a6
was played i did not understand this
idea king g2
first he developed his bishop to e7 to
defend g5
after training rooks boom queen a7
dropping the queen back
and b5 sending my queen away there was i
already understood at this point what he
wanted but there was nothing i could do
about it
and he wins the pawn and he wins the fun
and he won the game in another couple of
moves
both of my central pawns collapse and
the game is basically
over um so a brilliant idea
and i think it was repeated several
times now if we go back to the speed run
you guys can see the similarity and this
idea now i my aim is different
i'm not trying to win upon i'm trying to
you know organize in advance
but this concept of vacating a square
and then pushing upon
uh is is exactly the same we go c5
um and and immediately we open up the
bishop and we reap the fruits of our
labor instantly he blunders the pawn and
another one even if he didn't blunder it
uh we could have gone d5 or e4 i mean
he's under tremendous amount of pressure
here
if he goes d5 here uh what should white
do
what should white do in this position
all right uh knight e5 is fine
but also bishop takes c7 again remember
when the pawn is pushed particularly in
the center
remember to check which pawns have been
left behind take c7 and then we can put
our knight on e5
okay uh so after that the rest was very
simple this movement should be one
uh i think is actually quite a strong
one because we we prepare
once again that battery of the queen and
the bishop
so boom boom he goes g5 he helps us out
a little bit by bringing our bishop to
the central square
where it can take the knight on demand
and uh and now the move four right
adding some tabasco sauce
holy fire asks is 94 good instead of
building the bishop
queen battery sap gets his knight out of
the equation first so let's check
so knight e4 yeah that would have been
fine what i was a little bit concerned
about here
is the fact that my queen is on the same
file as one of his rooks
which means that i have to watch for
moves like g5 i know that that's not
possible here
but you always have to play with this
abundance of caution when possible
right sometimes that's not possible but
when you're winning
there's no need to play to live on the
edge if he goes g4 after f4 we take on
g4
he cannot capture with the knight the
knight is pinned if he captures with the
queen he leaves the h7 square unattended
which means we can take on f6 and
deliver that checkmate
so that's a key observation here right
how do i know to look for something well
i can see
that there's two pieces responsible for
guarding h7 the knight of the queen
i can take the knight whenever i want to
so what i'm really going for here is
something that would force this queen
out of g7
and that's why i'm increasing the
pressure on the knight on f6 because
it's not the knight i'm trying to
capture i could have done that earlier
it's that i'm trying to get his queen
out of the picture to deliver that
checkmate and that's exactly what i do
here
if he would have taken the rook i take
with the bishop and then of course
i deliver checkmate on h7 hopefully that
makes sense
when are we generally allowed to move
kingside pawns in the attack well
that's not there's no formula here right
it's a judgment
call but one of the things that you can
do is ask yourself does my opponent have
enough pieces
to counter-attack my king if i open up
the king's side right and sometimes the
answer is yes but the
the importance of opening up the king
site is is such that you will allow that
kind of risk right it's all about
weighing the risk and the benefit of
whatever it is you do there's never
really an algorithm
past a certain level there is when
you're a beginner but when you're 1700
you've got to make those judgment calls
there's no way to sort of
you know algorithmically reason your way
into it
okay let's play one more and then maybe
i'll switch over to some blitz
um yeah his pieces are tied down
defending so
that's part of the reason why i allowed
myself to open up the
king side right